this is a production of cornell
university
thanks very much teresa and i really
want to thank both you and
gillian for the invitation to to visit
cornell virtually
i've been to your campus several times
and really enjoyed it
and i'm also an alumnus of the cornell
medical school
in new york city so i have an affinity
for the university
and i don't know if you can see it but i
have my cornell hat right here
and we can put it on i think that might
be appropriate for
the seminar today and i have my fleece
which is from the wild cornell medicine
as well so we are doing our best to
advertise
here in north carolina the excellent
educational institution that you all are
associated with
let me go ahead and share my screen
and
does that show the first slide of the
powerpoint
excellent so as teresa mentioned i want
to
share with you today are a story about
our work
on a novel form of drug resistance
antimicrobial drug resistance
that we discovered in a basal fungus
mucours or sinaloides
and let's see
i want to begin the story with max
delbrook
and many of you know that max was a
physicist who
transition to work in genetics and
molecular biology
he was part of the phage school of
molecular biology
this is a pamphlet from a centennial
celebration of his birth that was held
in spain a number of years ago
that i had the opportunity to attend
and max
is famous for many different
contributions to science but one of
those is illustrated
here this is a paper published in
genetics in 1943
and many people referred to us as the
the fluctuation test
so salvador luria and max bellbrook
we're interested in what is the basis of
mutations that occur
in biological systems and they
distilled this down to the simplest
experimental system they used e coli
as the bacterial host and they
studied mutations that were occurring
that conferred resistance to a lytic
phage
t1 so you grow cultures of the bacteria
you expose them to the phage oops and
then plate out
and if you take one subculture and test
it multiple times you see a little bit
of experimental variation
in the number of resistant colonies that
arise
but the key experiment was to grow
multiple
subcultures expose those to the phage
and then you see a much more dramatic
variation in the level of resistance
particularly some of these have many
many resistant isolates and these are
a jackpot effect and it's attributable
to when the mutation arises in the
growth of the culture if it arises early
you have many resistant mutants if the
mutations arise late
you have very few or no resistant
mutants
so this was the experimental setup there
was a lot of detailed statistical
analysis
but it led them to conclude that
mutations spontaneously occur in
populations
and then selection acts upon those to
select the resistant
ones that are better suited to survival
under the stressful conditions
they went on to share the nobel prize
with
al hershey in 1969 for
discoveries concerning dna replication
and
genetic structure of viruses and a key
aspect of this was their
discovery of the basis for mutations
occurring to phage resistance and
generalizing that to thinking about
mutations in all populations for all
organisms al hershey you'll remember
from the hershey
chase experiment conducted with martha
chase
in which they showed that the dna of
phages was the genetic material rather
than the protein
so after max delbruck won the nobel
prize
he shifted entirely his research focus
and program to work on the organism
that's shown here
this is called phycomyces blake's lianas
and it's a fungus
it's a basal fungus it used to be part
of the
zygomycyc phyla of the fungal kingdom
now we know it as the mucoraelis
and he was particularly interested in
studying this as a model for sensory
perception because
these long sporangiopores are very
responsive to environmental cues and
this includes
light touch wind gravity and even the
presence of adjacent objects and
this is showing the light responsiveness
of the organism this
uh isolate on the left is a blind mutant
and the one on the right is responding
to a white
light source off the edge of the plate
and the sporangiopores reorient their
growth towards the light source
so when alex sidner was a postdoc in my
lab he was studying
light sensing and other properties in
cryptococcus but
his weekend hobby was to come in and
work on phycomyces he just fell in love
with this organism
and contributed a series
of publications on ficomyces
the first two were in collaboration with
louise corotrano
and arturo aslava's groups in spain and
involved identifying
the genes and the proteins involved in
light sensing
these are mutants that have been
isolated in max del brook's lab in the
60s mad a and mad b and they encode
orthologs of the white color one white
color two protein complex
that senses light and neurospora
alex went on to identify the mating type
locus
in this uh fungal species they it had
been earlier named
the sex locus these were studies
published in nature
will return to the sex locus as part of
the main story in just a few minutes
and then finally there was a large
consortium that came together
that was organized by louise corotrano
and victor garr and igor grigoria
who sequenced the genomes of both
phycomyces
and mucours cersei's this was published
in current biology just a few years ago
and what it revealed is that these
species have
undergone repeated whole genome
duplication events
we know about the whole genome
duplication event that punctuated the
evolution of saccharomyces cerevisiae
that's critical in producing
duplicated genes and paralogs with many
interesting biological functions
these species have undergone two whole
genome duplication events and
that turns out to be a recurrent theme
throughout biology and other
species as well and what one of the
consequences of that is it's
dramatically expanded the repertoire
of signal transduction proteins that are
available in these species
as well as some other pathways including
the rnai machinery as we'll see in a few
minutes
so i want to turn our attention then
to think about another species that lies
within the basal
fungi this is the fungal tree of life
here we know a lot about the ascomycota
and the basidiomycota because of model
species that populate those two phyla
things like saccharomyces cerevisiae
ustilago madis canada albicans and
neurospra for example
these have a monophyletic origin from
this green
point here and these are referred to as
the dicario they descend from a last
common ancestor
but all of these other um sort of blue
and orangish balloons here or other
phyla that we know about now from
molecular phylogeny and the fungal
kingdom
and we're going to be talking about the
mucoralis indicated by the red arrow
here
and both phycomyces and nucor
surcinaloides
and a human pathogen rhizopus horizon
lie within this group of fungi
and these are understudied organisms
and um the application of whole genome
sciences really opened a unique window
to be able to study them in detail
so we pivoted when su chan li arrived in
the lab as a postdoc
from working on phycomyces to focus on
mucor
because it's dimorphic it's a human
pathogen
and you can transform it and disrupt
genes by homologous recombination
and phycomyces is strictly hyphal
it's not a human pathogen and so far no
one's been able to transform it so it
remains
a challenging model system
so zygomyce fungi as a class
caused devastating human infections some
of those are illustrated here
and part of the reason these are so
devastating is because we have a very
limited
um armamentarium of anti-fungal drugs
really limited to just amphotericin b
posaconazole and isobuconazole in some
cases you require
surgery to control these infections
and there's a broad panoply of organisms
that cause
zygomicetus infections and they're
diverse and
understudied
we chose an area in which we wanted to
focus
in exploring the biology and the
pathogenesis of newborns or similarities
and we are studying calcineurin it's a
conserved calcium calmodulin activated
protein phosphatase
that in previous studies had been shown
to be required for pathogenesis
and other fungi in mucor
this petri dish here shows the standard
hypogrowth mode and under the microscope
you can see the branching hyphae that
are typically formed
but when we grew the organism on media
containing a calcineurin
inhibitor the natural product fk 506 you
see this small
restricted yeast colony and when you
look under the microscope these are
multibudded yeast
cells so this calcineurin inhibitor
completely blocks the dimorphic
transition from yeast to hyphae it turns
out that this had been discovered
earlier in fact by louise
by louis pasteur in 1876 rediscovered in
1962 by solomon
garcia namely that if you grow much
under anaerobic conditions with a little
bit of co2
i'm sorry oops sorry these slides keep
changing if you grow it with anaerobic
conditions you also see a multibudded
yeast so the calcineurin inhibitors
completely bypass this
normal anaerobic condition that's
required to lock the organism into the
yeast phase
so armed with this observation
cecilia schertz as a rotating graduate
student set out to understand
how this might operate so we know a lot
about
fk 506 as a natural product it diffuses
into the cell it binds to a protein
called
fkbp12 to form a high affinity complex
which then binds to and inhibits the
calciner and phosphatase
a complex of a catalytic a regulatory
subunit and calmodulin
similarly the other natural product
cyclosporin binds to cyclophyllin and
also inhibits
calcineurin these are
natural products that have come to
prominence because they're used as
immunosuppressive drugs
in transplant recipients they also have
extremely potent anti-fungal activity
and we've been
focusing on that in our studies we know
a lot about the structures of these
complexes so
on the right and the left these are the
actual x-ray crystal structures
determined by other groups and more
recently for the fungal orthologs
by our group and collaborators here's
fkbp12 bound to fk 506
docked on to a common surface of
calcineurin
it binds to a region that's distinct
from the active site
and it makes these inhibitors
exquisitely specific for inhibiting this
phosphatase
and no other and this is the mechanism
of both antifungal activity
and immunosuppressive activity in the
human immune system
so cecilia set out to isolate resistant
mutants
to this growth inhibitor fk 506
so again without drug you see a
hypogrowth mode
in the presence of the drug you see a
yeast colony and if you wait
you see drug-resistant hyposectors
emerging
so we purify these drug-resistant
sectors and characterize them
as you might imagine some of them result
from
standard mendelian mutations
in the known drug targets and some
isolates
of this category are shown here this is
a deletion of fkbp12
these are point mutations or other
substitutions on either calciner and b
or calciner and a that confer resistance
to fk
506 those allow us to essentially map
out the surface that the drug inhibitor
complex is docking onto
on calciner and a and b we can model how
these mutations confirm resistance
so this confirms that this drug is
acting through the known targets
in this fungal species but it doesn't
really shed a great deal of
new lighter information it's interesting
but what turned out to be even more
interesting was a second
class of drug resistant variants
and one such isolate is shown here this
is the control medium
here the wild type is sensitive to fk
506
this isolate is resistant to fk 506 and
it's also cross resistant to a second
drug
called rapamycin and like fk 506
rapamycin binds to fkbp12 and inhibits a
target in the cell
in this case called tor so the fact that
these
isolates are resistant to both drugs
implicates fkbp12 in their
the basis for their resistance so about
70 percent of the drug resistant
isolates have mendelian mutations in the
three known drug targets
but about 30 percent did not and the
question is what are these
unusual drug resistant isolates
by western blot using an antibody raised
against
yeast fkbp12 that cross reacts with the
mucor protein we could show that
fkbp12 is missing in these drug
resistant isolates
and by northern blot we could show that
the the gene is not being
expressed so the implication that
fkbp12 is somehow involved is borne out
by these findings
at this point cecilia came to my office
with a troubling look on her face and
said you know i'm really frustrated by
these mutants because
when i passage them they keep reverting
to being drug sensitive and she was
worried and upset about this and i said
you know i think that might be
interesting i think we should look more
carefully at this so
this table summarizes what we found two
wild-type strains
no matter how long you passage them they
always grow as a yeast in the presence
of fk 506 they're sensitive
if we delete the fkbp-12 gene it's a
rock-stable mendelian mutant it always
is resistant
to fk 506 and three of her
epi mutant variants you can see with
some
stochasticity for which passage they
revert
from being resistant to being sensitive
again so these isolates
unlike a mendelian mutation are unstable
and transient and the images
at the bottom here show the they become
sensitive again
to fk 506 and they also become just as
sensitive as the wild type
to rapamycin
now interestingly when these epimutants
revert to become drug sensitive the
expression of fkbp12 is restored at both
the protein level
and at the mrna level so they can become
drug resistant they
shut off expression of the key drug
target and then when they revert
magically it comes back on
so we considered a number of different
possible models for unstable drug
resistance and i want to focus
on the one that turned out to be the
explanation
we knew that mucor had an active rnai
pathway from work
going on in spain at the university of
mercia
in the labs of victor garr rosa ruiz
vasquez
and santiago torres martinez they and
their colleagues have been identifying
components of the rnai pathway including
dicer argonauts and rna-dependent rna
polymerases
contributing a series of publications on
this topic and
so we entertain the hypothesis that
these drug-resistant isolates might
involve spontaneous
rna silencing of the fkbp12 gene
to test that we made small rna
from the wild type the various forms of
the epi mutant grown in fk 506 in the
resistant form
or in the reverted sensitive form ran
them out and probed them
with a probe specific for antisense
rna to the fkbp12 gene encoded by the
fkba gene
and remarkably you'll see that all of
these epi-mutant isolates have abundant
small rnas to the fkbp12 locus but when
they revert to be sensitive
those all disappear we made
small rna libraries and sequence them so
we could look at the repertoire of small
rnas across the entire genome
and what this lower panel shows those
displayed across the fkvp12 gene
which has three exons the wild type has
no small rnas to the gene
the three different resistant epi
mutants all have abundant
smaller rnas to both the sense and
anti-sense strand
and when they revert those small rnas go
away
and notably you'll see that the introns
of the gene are not decorated by small
rnas
only the exons and so it implicates the
mature
mrna from the fkbp12 gene as being the
target
for the small rnas now importantly we
did not see any spreading of small rnas
to adjacent genes
we didn't see amplification of small
rnas
in the drug resistant isolates compared
to the wild type or the sensitive
isolates anywhere else in the genome
there certainly are other small rnas
many of which decorate
transposons throughout the genome but
they don't change
in response to the isolate becoming
resistant and sensitive so to a first
approximation
the only thing that has happened is this
gene has been silenced by rnai
we went on to take a genetic approach um
sylvia kala who had been a student with
rosa and santiago working on the rnai
pathways came to the lab
brought all our mutants with her and we
proceeded to
march our way through the rnai pathways
to look at which components are required
for this epi-mutation process
and it was a straightforward experiment
we would isolate
resistant isolates in the wild type or
in an rnai mutant
and then simply determine the percent
that were due to epi mutants
in the wild type it's routinely about 30
and in the uh rnai mutants that are
required for the pathway it's below
the limit of detection so we could show
that dicer one and two
one of the rna dependent rna polymerases
argonaut one the qipxo nuclease
and the rnha helicase were all required
for the formation of these drug
resistant epimute
we're interested in all of these but i
want to draw special attention to this
helicase
it turns out that that gene lies
immediately adjacent
to the mating type or sex locus in
mucours or sinaloides and other related
species
it's the open reading frame is not
strictly part of the sexually dimorphic
region of the mating type locus but
regions of the promoter we think differ
between the plus
and the minus mating type so that's
particularly intriguing that an rnai
component is linked
to the mating type locus given previous
studies in
cryptococcus and other fungi that rnai
pathways are often
activated during sexual reproduction
now this helicase turns out to be
interesting
in another respect and that is it's the
ortholog
of a helicase previously studied in
neurospora
that's been found to be required for an
rnai pathway
that mediates meiotic silencing of
unpaired dna
and what's interesting is rnha is the
direct
reciprocal blast hit to a helicase from
palm bay
which is itself is the best reciprocal
blast hit to sad
three but when we do this reciprocal
blast hits between
oops between neurosphera and mucor
it's the best hit in one direction but
it's the third best hit in the other
direction
we think it's the bonafide ortholog of
sad three but it suggests that sometimes
you have to do
uh more complicated phylogenetic
analysis
to ascertain this and the domain
structures of the helicases are shown at
the bottom here
so we're interested in further studies
on whether the sexual cycle of the
organism will be linked
to the process of rnai dependent epi
mutation
we could go on to show that some rnai
components are fully dispensable for
forming epimutants
that includes two of the argonauts
argonaut 2
and argonaut 3 they're fully dispensable
whereas argonaut one is required
and then there's a third class of rnai
components that's
perhaps the most intriguing and in these
mutants
there are three such mutants two
rna-dependent rna polymerases
and an alternative dicer called r3b2
you find a dramatic increase in rnai
dependent epi mutants and they're
dramatically stabilized and in fact some
of these have never been observed to
revert
so instead of finding 30 epi mutants we
find
in the range of 80 epi mutants and
they're stabilized
so we can take all of this information
and
marshal it into a model that depicts
multiple different rnai dependent
pathways
in nucor that function in parallel we've
been focusing on the epi-mutation
pathway
but in parallel victor gar and his
colleagues have defined an
alternative rna degradation pathway
and notably three of the unique
components in this pathway are the same
ones
that when they're mutated result in
channeling
more events through the epi-mutational
pathway so we think these two pathways
are competing
for aberrant rna to either degrade it or
to
channel it into the epi-mutation pathway
and you can fine-tune this
by mutating these components or we think
possibly by regulating
the function or the expression of these
components in response to different
environmental signals
now you may be wondering how did this
epi mutant form
in the first place and we considered the
same
question and in looking at the
annotation of the genome
what's quite striking is right next to
the fkbp12 gene is an adjacent gene
and they're in an inverted orientation
and in fact the three prime ends of the
messages overlap
by 92 base pairs and this provides the
potential for this region to form
double-stranded rna
and so we thought aha this must be the
trigger
for a dicer maybe the poly tails are
trimmed maybe
another enzyme extends these and then
you dice this and then that leads to
rnai silencing
so to test this model we deleted this
adjacent gene
by transformation and homologous
recombination
with the deletion allele shown here and
to our surprise
complete deletion of this region had no
impact on the formation of epi mutations
at fkbp12 so a good model
but we think that we can exclude this
model
and we went on to discover that there's
a naturally occurring antisense message
to the fkbp12 locus
that antisense like the sense message is
destroyed
when these epi mutants form when they
revert the sense and the antisense
message
return and by
generating c dna from this antisense we
can see that it's generated from the
mature spliced
fkbp12 mrna we think that an
rna-dependent rna polymerase might be
involved in generating it
but we've tested each of the single
mutants that we have available
and they all still make this antisense
so i think it may require some
biochemical approach of making
enzyme and seeing which of these might
be able to
copy the other strand to generate this
trigger
for the rnai pathway
so to summarize to this point we've seen
spontaneous fk 506
rapamycin resistant mutants can result
from either mendelian mutations that are
stable
or unstable epi mutations in the
epi mutants there's no change in the
fkbp12 gene
encoding fkbp12 the mrna and the protein
are absent there's abundant small rnas
and we think that this pathway could be
either regulated in some fashion or it
might be completely stochastic
in the same way that luria and delbrook
envisioned that mutations that occur in
a population
are just stochastic and then selection
acts upon them
and we think that it might be an
anti-sense that serves as a trigger
in some rare cells or nuclei the sense
and the anti-sense come together
that's a substrate for dicer and then an
epi mutant
arises in parallel with mendelian
mutations arising
from polymerase errors for example
now we went on to generalize this in two
ways and the first was to show that this
also occurs
in a second species of mucor and this
was of interest but it was also
a key challenge put to us by the
reviewers and the editors of our paper
that was ultimately published
in nature this took us something like
seven months to accomplish and
this experiment came together over the
very last part of that time frame so
it's quite amazing how
being required to demonstrate something
can serve as an impetus to do
experiments that
you might not have done otherwise but
we showed in two closely related species
they were originally
considered forma but they've now been
recognized as distinct species
mucorsinoloidis lucitanicus now mucour
lucitanicus
and mucoursocinoloides itself that we
find epi mutants
at 30 in the species we started with an
even higher frequency in the
mcc species shown here
now very recently uh cybernda hoag
and kirsten voight and gret walter have
published this key paper in presunia
where they've defined the species
complex here for
mucours or sinaloides and we've been
talking about cersenoloides and
lucitanicus but
you can see by the ps designation which
means
phylogenetic species there's 16
different species in this complex
of which at least five or six are human
pathogens
so we're quite interested now we've set
up a collaboration with grit
in her lab to bring in isolates across
the species complex and test
the whole panel for formation of epi
mutations
now the other major advance in this
paper is
for many years you could do sexual
crosses in muchor but no one had ever
seen the spores germinate so you could
not do a complete
sexual cross and this is the first
report
of zygosport germination from some of
the isolates reported in their
phylogenetic tree
so we're also quite excited about that
because for the first time we can do a
cross
and see if that might change the
frequency of epi mutations
and it might link it to that helicase
that's right next to the mating type
locus i should mention that we've tested
a lot of other stress conditions
and with the exception of infection
which i'll tell you about in a few
minutes
a panoply of other stress conditions in
vitro didn't seem to stimulate the
formation of epi mutations
um my graduate student zanetta chang who
is an md phd student
then extended this in another direction
and that was to identify epi mutations
in two additional genes this relied on
using a drug
5-fluorouric acid 5foa that was
popularized by the yeast genetics
community
because it selects for loss of function
in the urethria or the ura5 genes
and in mucor these are referred to as
pref and pure g
we spent quite a bit of time looking for
five of five foa resistant epi mutants
unsuccessfully
and then zanetta um took a page from um
this the delineation of the rnai
pathways and she started
with those rnai mutants that have a
higher frequency of epi mutants
a kind of genetic helping hand so in the
rdrp1 and rdrp3 mutant backgrounds
she was nicely able to isolate epi
mutants this is showing the small rna
blots either in the pure f
gene or in the pure g gene
i'm upon passage they revert to being
drug sensitive and small rnas
go away and when she sequenced
the small rnas they again decorate the
sense and the antisense strands
of the pure fg or of the pure
g gene the pure f gene has only an exon
no
introns the pure g gene has two introns
and again you can see the small rnas
are specific to the exons and not the
introns
of the genes so
that generalizes this now across at
least three other loci
in the genome total and we think that
epi mutations might in principle
be possible to form at any locus
throughout the genome
if you had a selection for it
now zanetta went on to do two other
experiments looking at epi mutations
in the mouse and the goal of the first
set of experiments was to take
a resistant epi mutant introduce it into
mice recover colony forming units from
different tissues
and just ask is the epi mutant stable
during infection
of a mouse and you'll see in liver
spleen kidney lung
there it's very very stable virtually
all her cfu are still resistant when
they come out of the mouse
but the isolates from the brain about
half of them have reverted to be
sensitive
so there's something unique about
infection of the central nervous system
the second experiment she did was to
take a drug sensitive isolate
infect mice recover from the same
tissues
and ask is there any induction of drug
resistance
in these isolates coming out of
different mouse tissues
and there was very little effect from
oops from liver spleen kidney or lung
but from the brain you see
about seven percent of the isolates
coming out of the brain
form fk 506 resistant isolates on a
petri dish
so there's something unique about the
central nervous system
that we think is inducing plasticity of
the rnai system either for reversion
or for induction and it might have to do
with for example
expression levels of the competing rnai
pathways at least we think that is a
workable hypothesis
to pursue
the last experiment that zanetta did was
to infect mice
recover colony forming units from the
brain and the liver
culture these for four days six days or
eight days in vitro
and then i ask are there any small rnas
that are induced by
infection in the mouse and
from this heat map you can see there's a
series of seven genes
that have abundant small rnas induced
against them
in isolates recovered from the brain and
it's
in for me it was quite remarkable that
this worked because this is four days
and six days and eight days
of culture after recovery from the
animal
it turns out six of those genes are
completely unknown
but one of them is an ortholog or a
homolog
of a stress activated kinase involved in
stress responses and other fungi
work by carlos and maribel who were in
victor garr's lab and
are arriving soon in durham to join the
lab as postdocs
they've been looking at rna-seq and
small rnas
in the context of macrophage infections
what's quite remarkable is this
bep a gene you can see that its
expression is reduced in macrophages
and we think that that could be as a
consequence
of these small rnas coming on so these
would be naturally occurring epi
mutations
against different loci induced in the
brain in response to infection
now this is preliminary data so this was
done
with new core lucitanicus and
macrophages this was done with mucours
through sinuloides
in the whole animal model so clearly we
have some additional work to do here
of exposing both of these environments
to isolates from the same species so we
can do a
more direct comparison
our plans for this part then and you can
see that this is
aim2 of the r01 that's been submitted on
this
is to study the epi mutations in the
context of the brain
both in macrophage cell culture in
blood brain barrier models in a brain
organoid model with our colleague debbie
silver who's located one floor below
our lab and growing brain organoids and
then finally to
micro dissect different regions of the
brain
rather than treating the brain just as
one whole
tissue to ask whether or not there are
specific regions of the brain in which
these epi mutants are reverting or being
induced
we're also planning to delete these
seven novel
genes and test whether or not there's an
impact on the infectious cycle
uh by generating a mendelian mutation at
those loci
that are being impacted by an rnai epi
mutation
so i want to summarize that epi
mutations are general and occur in two
related species
they've been found so far in three genes
they can be like mutations stochastic
and they can also be strictly epigenetic
if we take
one of those fk 506 resistant epi
mutants
let it revert and select epi mutants
again
they occur at the same frequency it's 30
percent of the population
so we think that it's strictly
epigenetic but as i mentioned for the
pirate and pure gp mutants those
occurred in an rnai mutant background as
a genetic helping hand
and so you can envision pathways that
have both the genetic and then an
epigenetic component occurring as well
so from one common selective pressure
we found two different types of isolates
mendelian mutants
that are stable and epi mutants
that are rnai dependent and transient
and unstable
and we think that this allows organisms
to sample a much broader phenotypic
space they don't make a permanent
commitment to the loss of fkbp12
they just shut it down for the period of
time they need to
and then it can be restored when the
selective pressure is relaxed
now i want to close by generalizing this
and epi mutations
were discovered originally in plants
and this is a snapdragon
the wild type snapdragon has bilateral
symmetry across the flower
this is a variant that was discovered by
carl linnaeus
the famous botanist and phylogenist
something like four centuries ago it has
radial symmetry
and the report of the gene just over 20
years ago
showed that um the polaric flower it's
not a mutant it's an epi mutant
there's no nucleotide changes in the
underlying gene it's extensively heavily
methylated
and it's stable enough to have been
passed through flower crosses for
centuries
so it's state can be stable through
meiosis and occasionally it'll revert
back to wild type
epi mutants have also been described in
humans
so you're probably familiar with
a human genetic cancer predisposition
syndrome it's called either hereditary
non-polyposis colorectal cancer hnpcc
that's a bit of a mouthful so it's now
more commonly known as
lynch syndrome these
individuals and families have mutations
in the mismatch repair pathway and that
leads them to have
inherited cancer predisposition in some
of these families though they didn't
find
any mutations in the suspect genes
and you can see three different reports
of epi mutations occurring in either
mlh1 or msh2
and there are a variety of other reports
of human epi mutations
again in this case it's not rnai it's
methylation
of the gene that shuts down expression
very recently there's a paper published
by robin allshire in nature this is
published september 9th
of this year and they identified epi
mutations in schizosaccharomyces palm
bay
by selecting for caffeine resistance and
then screening
for isolates where the resistance is
unstable
and showing that their resistance is
dependent on a heterochromatin factor
clr4 that makes the heterochromatic mark
h3k9 dimethyl when they
chipped in the genome for the location
of h3k9 dimethyl
you light up the centromeres of the
three chromosomes as you expect
but in each of these unstable resistant
isolates
another region of the genome lights up
as
having been turned in to heterochromatin
and in this case there's four or five
genes that are covered by the
heterochromatic peak
and one of those genes has already been
implicated in caffeine resistance so you
can have epi mutations that result from
rnai
or for dna methylation or for
heterochromatin formation and it
suggests that
other organisms other fungi
oomy seeds human pathogens plant
pathogens that have heterochromatin or
rnai
might be subject to these types of
pathways
so i want to summarize then we focused
on rnai
and epi mutations as a for a form or a
generator of phenotypic diversity
but there's a panoply of other factors
that can also contribute to microbial
diversity including things like hsp90 as
a capacitor for evolution
prions aneuploidy mutators and
hypermutators
and sexual and parasexual reproduction
and all of these contribute
to generate a pallet of diversity that
selection can act upon in promoting
uh diversification and evolution of
both populations and species
and uh there's two plus pearls reviews
that summarize other aspects of these
diversity generators in case anyone is
interested
i want to close by thanking the members
of the group that contributed to this
so the epi mutation project started when
cecilia was
a rotating student in the lab and then
was continued by sylvia
as a postdoc and su chan was a critical
component in working on new core in the
lab zanetta did all of the animal work
and the
prf and pure gp mutants blake bill meyer
who's now at the stowers institute was
the bioinformatic muscle for the entire
project
this was a long-term collaboration with
rosa and santiago and
kuro in the university of mercy on spain
and carlos and maribel have been
contributing critical data analysis to
the latter parts of the project
as part of victor garr's lab at the same
university
and i want to thank all the members of
my group i'd like to acknowledge the
long-term support
from the nih including a key
training program that teresa mentioned
we're very grateful for all of this
support and
i i'd like to also highlight that this
is a program
that's now supported also by the
canadian institute for advanced research
called fungal kingdom
threats and opportunities i'll stop
there and be happy to take any questions
if there's time
thank you very much for a wonderful
seminar
thank you we have
a question from
eric and then uh from gillian
in the chat eric no thank you very much
so quick question so if you um look at
your epigenetic resistant
um organism and then essentially make an
si rna library
do you think that you're going to see
depletion of lots of different si rnas
you know is this like a sort of a global
phenomenon that many that you're having
a control of lots of the si rnas
or is it something specific to the
resistance of the
um drug that you're testing so
from the libraries that we've made for
the
fkbp 12 resistant mutants
and for the 5 foa resistant mutants
essentially all we see is small rnas
increasing in abundance to those target
genes
all the other small rnas that we see
across the genome
seem to be at the same level of
abundance in the
the wild type the resistant isolate and
the revert and isolate
so the way we're thinking about it is if
you look at a whole population of mucor
say a billion cells there'll be
a cell here that has more small rnas to
one
gene and there'll be a cell here that
has more small rnas to another gene
and a cell here that has small rnas
to another gene but uh
we're not sure that there would be an
intermediate that had say a lot of small
rnas across the genome
and we may be thinking about that in the
wrong way but
we're thinking of it similar to how
mutations occur
but it could also be the case when
you're growing a culture that you get
bursts of mutation as well
so for the ones that come out of the
brain
we've only analyzed those cfu as a whole
population
and we see seven genes that have an
increase
in small rnas and what we don't know
is does every cell coming out of the
brain
have small rnas increased against all
seven of those genes
or by analyzing it as a pool and we
combine
seven different epi mutants in our
analysis
so we want to repeat that experiment
and include colony purification as part
of it
to begin to address that
so this sounds like more like a
chromatin structure kind of change then
would that be your thought um we
actually
don't think there's going to be a change
in the chromatin structure
we've been um struggling with some of
the reagents to be able to prove that
definitively
um it's certainly possible that there's
some
heterochromitin but the fact that
the the trigger is the mature mrna
we think means that it might be
post-transcriptional and it might not
involve heterochromatin because
if you were to form heterochromatin you
you might imagine you wouldn't have any
rna there to continue the process
thanks
gillian you had a question that's in the
chat i see
is there any association or connection
of the epi mutation phenomenon
to the whole genome duplication that
that's a great question um
so we don't know and
what we so when we tried to generalize
this to other species we spent some time
trying to look for epi mutations in
neurospora and in cryptococcus
unsuccessfully and
we then went back and said let's look at
the closest species we can look at
so we are thinking about broadening that
now to these 16
phylogenetic species but they've all
undergone this whole genome duplication
event so
we need isolates that would undergo this
that are further away
and i think we're going to try harder
with cryptococcus and um
we've been hoping that somebody would
find this in neurosphere or aspergillus
in the meantime um
yeah you pre-empted my
second question um has this
been demonstrated for any plant pathogen
not that i'm aware of and
you know the silvia's paper was
published in
2014 and i thought there might be a
flurry
of reports that followed that
but um it it took some time
and robin alshires i think is really the
first example
there is another paper that i skipped
over at the end there
in the interest of time where they
characterize
fluconazole resistant cryptococcus
isolates and about half of them turn out
to be
aneuploid for one chromosome or another
but the other half
does they're unstable and they don't
have any aneuploidy
and they don't know what the mechanism
is
so we would like to make small rna
libraries of those isolates and see if
they
might be epi mutants and i think that
that could be a good
starting point i think for plant
pathogens
given robin allshire's paper you could
entertain the idea that they might be
either
heterochromatin or they might be rnai or
given the plant and the human work they
might be dna methylation
right so any any of these mechanisms
could give rise
to something that might be unstable at
some level
thank you any other questions
i have a question then then um so much
are famous for their resistance to
various anti-fungal agents um
do you think uh that there is a common
mechanism uh related to
your recent discoveries or these um
these um ability the ability to to
withstand
the the pressure is
by different mechanisms so
it's one of the defining features i
think of the mucouralies as a human
pathogen and
they are intrinsically resistant to a
lot of drugs
and when you look at rnai mutants that
couldn't
form an epi mutation they don't become
more sensitive
to those drugs
we think there are other reasons
in the case of some of the azoles basils
can have a short
or a medium or a long tail
and there are some amino acid
substitutions in erg 11 the target of
the azoles
that make much resistant to some azoles
but still sensitive to
things like isobuconazole
tobias hall was visiting one time and we
presented this story to him and he said
you know it's pretty interesting but it
would be a lot more interesting
if you could show this would be relevant
to a drug we actually use in people
and so we are planning to look for epi
mutants that might make you resistant to
amphotericin b
or poseiconazole or isobuconazole
and it turns out you can get loss of
function mutations in their
gastro biosynthetic pathway that could
do that so an
earth-six mutant should be amphotericin
b resistant and erg-free mutant or
epimutant
would be azoll resistant some of those
are
one of those genes is triplicated in
mucor so
that might be a unique case where it'd
be easier to get an epi mutant than a
loss of function mutation
so when carlos and maribel arrive
that's part of what we're planning to
pursue
and that might then link it to um
mechanisms of drug resistance there's a
lot of
drug resistance occurring i think in
both plant and human fungal pathogens
that's in response to azoll pressure
in agriculture this is a huge problem
with
aspergillus fumigatus and there's the
suspicion that it might be contributing
to
canada oris drug resistance
infections come from the environment so
we're also going to look at agricultural
azoles as well
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu